more than 2,900 flights are canceled
nationwide today as this winter storm
barrels north all runways in Charleston
South Carolina remain closed this
morning due to five inches of snow and
ice the severe weather is hampering
airports up and down the East Coast Kris
Van Cleave is monitoring travel
conditions from Reagan National Airport
outside Washington Chris good morning
here in the DC area even before the Sun
came up we had more than 250 flights
canceled whether you're trying to get in
from Boston or down south in Charleston
you're seeing a lot of canceled on these
boards and delays are mounting in
Philadelphia more than a hundred and
thirty flights have been canceled so
when you get to New York though that you
really start to see the cancellations
pile up more than 1,700 flights going
through New York's three busiest
airports JFK Newark and LaGuardia are
grounded Newark has taken the brunt of
the cancellations so far but we expect
Boston Logan as well as Providence and
Hartford airports to be hit the hardest
flights are not expected to operate
there until late tonight nearly 700
flights in Boston alone are canceled and
we expect that will climb nationwide
American Airlines and Delta have
combined canceled more than a thousand
flights today flights are already being
canceled for Friday
now the airlines have issued travel
waivers that allow people to make
changes without a fee and the goal for
the airlines is to begin resuming
service today as that storm moves north
they'll start flying in the south with
the hope of having somewhat normal
operations by Friday Chris thanks you're
only going to get worse in New England
as the day goes on here